[Music]
I'll just get a glass of water please I
have to save all my money cuz I'm here
to find my sister
she's been taken taken like like my man
who sell hot white Vergennes to
conchiglie in airs on yours
I am very moved by your story or there
anything you like I'll have a club
sandwich and an order fries she slices a
cake do you want any cake
no three slices of cake and a diet coke
impressive I'm a con artist
sisters-in-arms
I had no idea how small-time I was until
I met you depending why women better
suited to calm than men cuz we're used
to faking it because no man will ever
believe a woman is smarter than he is is
it valuable
$500,000 I like it cuz it's shiny
I could be the partner you live in you
needed teach me your sugar baby ways
thank you to the guest room battery
person first listen there's nothing more
compelling to a man than a vulnerable
woman upset wow you just tear up quite
bad can you make the tea roll down your
cheek oh oh no you try are you
constipated if you want to be like me
you must be trained before any situation
[Music]
she's ready he's the mark he's a
millionaire billionaire a bear try to be
inconspicuous as possible
walking here if this person would just
scoot over
would you mind sir sir
[Music]
men always underestimate us and that is
what we use
you let her get away huh she dresses
again sir Mossman says it suits her very
balanced is a terrible short that wasn't
expected
what do men what oops no backtalk front
door picking I'm gonna threesome what
what is it what's the answer they want
to be heroes there's nothing more
compelling to a man than a vulnerable
woman observe Wow you just tear up like
that you can just balance a tear right
on that lower lid and can you make the
tea roll down your cheek oh oh okay but
can you make it go back up no you try
okay are you constipation why are the
theatrics your heart that's enough it is
not enough hot is not a career hot will
get you give some trinkets but you must
pay for them in other ways sex penny
what do you want penny I want this I had
no idea how small time I was until I met
you teach me you sure the baby weighs
shape me I'm just something great and
richer and why would I do that because
who knows I could be the partner you
never knew you needed
no thanks I work alone okay I get it but
what you're not getting is that a girl
like me could make it real uncomfortable
for you in this town
just take one phone call
hello Interpol tell me penny why are
women better suited to the con than men
cuz we used to faking it it comes down
to one universal truth no man will ever
believe a woman are smarter than he is
we will always be underestimated
and that is what we use so this means
you're gonna teach me honey I'm teaching
you now wait pause that last part
I couldn't hear you were talking into
the ocean yep
oh how didn't the intrusion because
somebody tell me if there's an empty
chair at this table no man was they lit
a blissful Oh Vicky's taking Oh miss
miss excuse me you can have mature Oh
here oh but it's not necessary
perhaps if from his personal scoots over
we could just squeeze in another chair
well
Jemaine sir would you mind right behind
you oh thank you
well wonderful Quan person etiquette my
Nana was blind was she I have no idea
please place your bets
there's nothing more compelling to a man
than a vulnerable woman observe Wow can
you make the tea roll down your cheek oh
oh no you guys dude are you constipated
the hustle follows two female con
artists and how the way play is
high-class is it valuable this is very
valuable yes five hundred thousand times
I like it cuz it's shiny and I myself
play low rent and the movie follows us
meeting and then pulling these cons on
guys who maybe not the honest guys that
you would want them to be Jeremy I know
sorry Josephine's gonna con artists for
a long time she has a very set credo
very professional and any rust comes
into her life and the to get caught up
in a bunch of different cons when I've
been working here if this person were
just screwed over would you mind sir
sir they run this comic Jasmine's always
wanted to do but never had somebody to
do it with you truly believe she's ready
for something some elaborate really
excited about the Hortense sequence I'm
just gonna leave it at that I felt
really lucky that I had Anna Hathaway by
my side who really did rely on our
chemistry together and we look like a
classic comedy double act - like hands
taller and skinnier and I'm shorter and
bigger you know rebel she's an
unbelievably funny performer oh oh did I
spill something just now there was some
really fun times like on set I mean not
on every movie do you get to share
experiences like that I'm hoping that
the audiences have as much fun seeing it
as we had making it
[Music]